when you're updating something that was
essentially set in the future but from
the past it is it's it's a little bit of
that that feeling of walking in
Tomorrowland at Disney where you're like
that happened 20 years ago and the
emblematic conversation was this idea
that they walk around with their
communicators and they kind of look
though because they flip these things is
like okay nobody has those anymore yeah
this is supposed to be three hundred
years from now but at the same time
staying true to what is essentially
classic Trek and I do think that as the
original crew that's a William Shatner
and Leonard Nimoy and DeForest Kelley
etc as they moved into the into the
cinematic age they started making the
the motion pictures in in the 80s even
they were like we're not we're going to
ditch the uniforms the sort of primary
colors the yellows and the blues and the
Reds and that was another that one of
the first things that JJ and are
incredibly brilliant production designer
Scott Chambliss sort of sat down and and
Michael Kaplan our costume designer
basically said there's got to be a way
to do this this is classic Trek but you
know we should be in these kind of
primary colors so we don't need to make
it kind of look cool but i think that
there's also a palette that we can
modernize it so i think that the the
movie is constantly sort of embracing
and modernizing that vision of the
future extrapolated from the past one of
those i want to talk about and well as
we get everyone back up here is the
degree to which departments of sort of
blurred together and so it used to be
you know writing is a thing that
happened way in advance and then once
you knew what the movie was we were
going to make then he would start you
know the director would start
pre-visualization in your suit and
different people would come on and they
do their little jobs all those jobs tend
to happen kind of simultaneously and
overlapping in this way so one of the
things that we all decided would be very
cool was to sort of treat this Trek
movie a little bit like a James Bond
film where you kind of meat bond
finishing up whatever mission he had
from the movie that you didn't get to
see it's like that it's like the third
act like the greatest Bond movie never
shot and so we wanted to to meet up with
the enterprise
crew already in process but we also
wanted to make sure that that store that
the beats the emotional beats of that
adventure sort of resonated and and
everything that happens in that opening
sequence actually creates the
circumstances that follow it but we
started talking about here are the
mechanics of that scenario here's what
it looks like and so even though we
haven't even really figured out the
second the second or third act
specifically at we had that and so JJ
was able to start riffing on that and
presenting that to our production design
team Roger guyett guy at our amazing
visual effects supervisor the editors
Marion and Mary Jo who are already
creatively engaged before we've you know
months before we've shot a frame of film
you know I've got a wonderful script
that I follow and I and we have a
previous visualization that we work with
and we cut in shots but mostly we leave
in the green screens and then hand them
over to a we get a lot of temp
visualizations in there as we go it's
story driven so as long as you have the
dialog in the story and a lot of title
cards it seems to work well talk to my
title card so what's how hard is saying
like this is what happens in the shot
that is no longer it does not exist yet
right like here the enterprise rises out
of the ocean and when answers that still
a black screen or this oversized sounds
so ridiculous when you say about that
yeah you know we do a lot of work
together with Roger or the effects
supervisor and say hey what you know we
want this to be this long and he says
well that's 150 thousand dollars and
make it half the life we could maybe do
it four hundred thousand dollars so um
he actually wears a little green visor
dachshund I guess got ya exacting we
actually have had to recut scenes
because if Jeffrey or Roger would say we
absolutely do not have the money to to
do the scene the way you've cut it and
it's like really it's so good this way
though like what can we give I remember
on the first Trek I did it there's an
opening scene where there was a battle
in space and I put in a whole bunch of
black title card saying and then we
outside in the enterprise is battling
with the Narada and Roger came in and
went you just added two million dollars
to the budget I was like but it's a
battle in space yeah it'll be in space
the other thing that's interesting about
previous on and definitely not all of
our action sequences in this film were
previous but then sometimes JJ will just
make an offhand comment like and just
ignore the previous know until you do
ignore the previous and he goes didn't
you look at the previous yeah so for
people who aren't familiar with previous
what does it look like when it comes to
you because I the stuff I've seen often
sort of feels like a video game kind of
it looks like a cartoon you can take the
cartoon shot of the enterprise rising
out of the water and put it in your cut
so that you know it helps the director
or whoever's looking at it see what the
actual see how the actual sequence is
going to play and it's quite a bit more
dramatic than seeing the title card say
that the script helps enormously so it's
the first clue to what we're actually
trying to help create so you help them
so what I'm here for